this is the gig that you've had for how
many years now even Glenn is seven years
seven years you've been wet it's a long
time and now yeah it's that's always
worried about like what do you what are
you gonna do next oh actually I'm okay
uh yeah yeah I actually I got a new job
already you got a new job yeah I'm
actually um I stand in for you at
rehearsal you stand in for me here at
rehearsal yeah here yeah you don't so
funny I heard about this recently I
don't come in for rehearsals as you can
tell Andy and I are flown in by
helicopter seconds before the show
begins but no I don't I don't hang out
at rehearsal and and I they said that
someone was filling in for me it's you
me that's me I think don't they ever
don't they work they have porting of it
we had that we have recording of us
Steven filling in for me at rehearsal in
school look at me I'm Conan interview
talk to you this knee would joke
interview band cut - everyone's fired
now you're just gonna listen to me play
guitar for four hours you are gonna be
funny gonna be funny
we do this
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
you